public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation est l'invité de
l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir madame la
ministre
et merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté cette
invitation de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et avec la fp
médias représentés ce soir par lucile
bréau et paul aubry à bonsoir bonsoir à
tous deux en matière d'innovation madame
la ministre puisque c'est également
votre responsabilité vous avez fait donc
sensation avec cette réforme de l'accès
à l'université qui a donc donné lieu et
qui donne encore nous allons en parler à
contestation dans quelques
établissements de moins en moins
nombreux d'ailleurs on peut le constater
ce soir nous répondrait au cours de
cette émission à trois grandes questions
injustement le déblocage par la police
des facs qui s'est poursuivie ce matin à
grenoble et montpellier at il eu raison
selon vous de ce mouvement étudiant
deuxième question est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite de la mise en oeuvre de
parcours super puisque les lycéens ont
maintenant exprimer leurs voeux alors
qu'est ce que vous avez à leur dire nous
verrons cela tout à l'heure enfin
troisième question
l'université française peut-elle encore
tenir son rang face à la concurrence
mondiale on peut dire que les
classements internationaux ne sont pas
toujours flatteur pour notre pays
première question donc de cette émission
que va vous poser palau bria
[Musique]
mais des messages des facs qui s'est
poursuivie ce matin à grenoble et à
montpellier at il eu raison du mouvement
étudiant alors ce qui s'est produit ce
matin à grenoble à montpellier c'est de
nature différente
montpellier il n'avait plus l'étudiant
et c'était simplement un constat des
dégâts qu'ils avaient qui avait été
engendrés ces dernières semaines qui
s'est produit sur sur grenoble
présidents d'université a effectivement
demandé à ce que un site puisse être
rendue aux étudiants et aux enseignants
de manière à ce que les choses se
déroulent normalement
alors l'association s'apprécie vraiment
université par université club allemand
quand même est-ce que vous estimez
effectivement que ces déblocages qui se
succèdent en aura peut-être d'autres
encore marque la fin ont eu raison de ce
mouvement
non moi je crois que une fois de plus un
il faut distinguer deux choses il faut
distinguer les endroits où un petit
nombre de personnes ont confisqué
l'université ont commis des violences
des dégâts etc et où le président
d'université estime qu'il n'est plus en
capacité parce que parfois il n'a plus
le même accès aux locaux d'assurer la
sécurité des personnes et des biens est
donc là évidemment eh bien ils demandent
à la police
une intervention et c'est à ce moment là
le rôle de la préfecture de juger de
l'opportunité de l'intervention
et puis il ya des endroits où c'est le
débat qui a lieu ça c'est normal dans
les universités et où il ya des
assemblées générales où toutes les
opinions peuvent s'exprimer
c'est une différence fondamentale avec
les assemblées générales dans lesquels
seuls quelques individus ont la parole
et les autres sont exclues et ne peuvent
parfois même pas entrer un point assez
précis aujourd'hui de la situation dans
les universités françaises
est ce que vous savez précisément
combien sur toute la france sont
aujourd'hui bloqués ce soir encore alors
on a trois universités qui sont qui sont
bloqués sur 70 ans bien sûr 73
universités et
université en fait c'est plusieurs
facultés plusieurs sites à peu près 400
400 sites universitaires en france et il
y en a sept qui sont perturbées alors il
ya des blocages à lyon par exemple
encore quelques quels sont les les
universités concernées
alors il y à un bâtiment à à metz un
autre un an signe de mémoire bloquées à
rennes ii actuellement
voilà mernel également appelés à voter
le blocage jusqu'au 2 mai si je ne
m'abuse seulement bon on a vu que
tolbiac avaient été évacués dans les
conditions qu'on connaît par les crs
au milieu de la nuit la semaine dernière
est ce que la même chose au à se
produire à nanterre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous signez un petit peu
la fin de la récré vous siffler la fin
de la récré ou dit bon voilà il ya eu le
temps du débat maintenant il faut que
les examens puissent se tenir
est ce que les forces de l'ordre doivent
procéder de la même manière à nanterre 4
albiac alors à nanterre le président de
l'université
un matin en découvrant une bande
d'individus cagoulés et armés de barres
de fer en train de rentrer par
effraction dans un bâtiment a
effectivement fait appel aux forces de
l'ordre parce qu'ils ne savaient pas ce
qu'ils étaient en train de se passer et
il y avait un réel danger
on n'est plus dans cette situation
actuellement actuellement il est en
train de discuter avec avec les
étudiants de manière à ce que les
examens puissent se tenir normalement au
cours du mois de mai il faut bien
comprendre que les étudiants qui
bloquent les universités actuellement
sont en train de pénaliser les étudiants
qui sont les plus fragiles
les étudiants qui sont que j'ai
travaillé pour payer leurs études les
étudiants boursiers ceux qui ont
absolument besoin d'avoir leur diplôme
pour candidater sur des masters donc la
tenue des examens
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important tous les présidents
d'université ils sont attachés et bien
sûr je ferai en sorte de les aider à ce
que les examens se tiennent dans leurs
locaux ou dans d'autres locaux mais la
semaine dernière on a beaucoup parlé du
blocage de tolbiac la semaine dernière
sept mille étudiants ont passé néanmoins
leurs examens la semaine dernière deux
mille étudiants ont passé leur examen à
montpellier les examens se sont déroulés
à l'est
ils sont en train de se dérouler dans
plusieurs sites universitaires pour
certains cette dernière ait commencé de
cette semaine vous aurez vous ce
mouvement de contestation quand
justement tout l'examen auront été
passés enfin dans quelles modalités on
va en parler aussi mais vous estimez que
vous aurez vaincu ce mouvement à ce
moment là moi je crois que c'est très
important je ne cherche pas à vaincre le
mouvement je cherche simplement à
comprendre quelles sont les causes
d'inquiétude qui s'exprime
lorsque ce sont de vraies inquiétudes de
manière à pouvoir expliquer quel est
l'objet de cette réforme et je le
rappelle c'est d'abord une meilleure
orientation ensuite c'est qu'on ne tire
plus au sort les étudiants lorsqu'ils
rentrent à l'université et enfin ces
données à chaque étudiant ce dont il a
besoin pour réussir
et ça c'est quand même assez nouveau moi
j'ai longtemps enseigné en première
année par plaisir parce que pour moi
c'est un plaisir d'enseigner en première
année d'université et je sais très
exactement à quel point c'est difficile
pour les enseignants chercheurs de voir
les amphis se vider au cours des
semaines passées de blocage et aussi
beaucoup de dégâts aujourd'hui à combien
vous estimez ces dégâts sur l'ensemble
des facs qui ont été occupées alors les
estimations elles sont en cours une
toulouse notamment qui a fait l'objet
d'une énorme rénovation en 2016 la fac
le parvis de la cité jean jaurès pour
350 millions d'euros il a priori à
énorme et donc là c'était le coût de la
rénovation
a priori il ya énormément de bien vous
pouvez d'hiroshi alors sur toulouse j'ai
pas d'estimation précise le président de
l'université montpellier iii annonce à
peu près 300 mille euros de dégâts sur
les salles de serveurs l'université je
choisis donc sur l'université de tolbiac
m'a parlé de vie sont en cours mais on
parle aussi de
deux à trois cents mille euros et qui
doit payer au final parce qu'à un moment
c'est des gars il va falloir que
quelqu'un les assume est-ce que vous
encourager les présidents d'université a
porté plainte
est-ce que c'est à ceux qui ont occupé
de finalement assumé le coût de ces
dégâts c'est à l'état de prendre en
charge
on fait comment alors je n'ai pas à les
inciter à quoi que ce soit mais
effectivement que certains présidents
d'université font faire des
constatations par la police
effectivement avec pour objectif
derrière de pouvoir porter plainte parce
que c'est important
maintenant comme je voulais dire lorsque
des individus ont été identifiés en
train de casser il était souvent
cagoulés la démonstration va être
difficile mais il n'empêche que c'est
important de savoir qui a commis ses des
gardes parce que effectivement c'est le
contribuable qui qui va payer l'argent
des universités c'est de l'argent public
et voilà pour financer les universités
gala la difficulté c'est évidemment moi
je ne souhaite pas que l'argent qui a
été investi notamment pour mieux
accueillir les étudiants soient utilisés
pour repeindre des amphis pour faire des
serveurs donc voilà c'est je serai à
côté des présidents pour trouver avec
les meilleures solutions qui ne pénalise
pas leur université
mais pas d'estimation du coût global
alors on va je pense qu'on dépassera le
million d'euros le million d'euros pour
l'ensemble non une heure du conte en a
on est déjà quasiment 600 milles sur les
autres ebooks toulouse comme si vous
avez vécu ce week-end la rumeur d'un
étudiant plongé dans le coma après
l'intervention des forces policières à
tolbiac est ce que vous avez
régis est ce que vous considérez que
ceux qui ont propagé cette rumeur
doivent s'excuser médias de de la france
insoumise l'unef également accréditer la
thèse de cet étudiant dans le coma j'ai
trouvé ça absolument abjecte il n'ya pas
eu d'étude en encore non mais sûr que
non je confirme qu'il ya pas eu d
étudiantes comme un jeu je trouve que
c'est abject je reprendrai volontiers
les mots de raphaël enthoven sur le
sujet c'est voilà je crois qu'il a dit
que l'étudiant blessés que l'on invente
c'est peut-être le mort que l'on
souhaite je trouve que c'est
incroyablement violent de faire ça je
trouve que c'est une voix lasse et c'est
pour moi c'est inadmissible c'est
inqualifiable
je pense à aux gens qui ont le malheur
de perdre quelqu'un de jeune dans leur
entourage en leur famille faire passer
ce type de rumeur effectivement ce donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on cherche
vraiment concentré vous vous attendez
peut-être des excuses aujourd'hui de jeu
certains s'explique moi je j'attends
tout au moins que les personnes qui ont
colporté ces rumeurs effectivement
reconnaissent que ces rumeurs sont
fausses
g j'ai noté effectivement sur quels
types de médias elle avait été propagée
par tel type de personne le média est le
média qui qui a avait l'air de se
réjouir absolument de cette nouvelle qui
lui a permis de faire du buzz
je trouve que c'est tout sauf du
journalisme
qu'est ce que ça dit de ce mouvement de
notre époque
plus globalement parce qu'on parle aussi
beaucoup de ces fakes news qui se
propage qu'on a du mal à endiguer qu'est
ce que ça dit de notre époque de son ca
dit probablement que au moins pour
partie il y a une envie d'
instrumentaliser des choses et une envie
de se mettre en scène ya une envie de
théâtre et une envie de faire croire que
les quelques centaines d'étudiants qui
bloque représentent la majorité des
étudiants chaque fois qu'une
consultation électronique est fait
l'écrasante majorité des étudiants sont
contre le blocage souhaite passer
un examen c'est un peu la démocratie
confisquée
lorsqu'on organise des regroupements
dans lesquels on interdit l'accès à
certains étudiants parce qu'ils ne
partagent pas les idées lorsque l'on
tags des locaux de l'union des étudiants
juifs de france
lorsqu'on écrit sur les murs un bon flic
est un flic mort la semaine où on
célèbre le collen beltrame et où on à
l'attentât de trèbes
voilà lorsqu'on est capable de faire ce
genre de choses c'est que on veut
instrumentaliser les universités on veut
instrumentaliser les étudiants et
l'université ne se laisse pas
instrumentaliser en tout cas moi j'en
suis convaincu en tant qu'universitaire
vous avez été heurté par certains
ateliers qui se sont tenues dans
certaines facs je conduire ils ont cogné
en ont mixé aux unions à ses racines
vous avez là certains mettent en cause
par exemple la présence des indigènes de
la république dans l'organisation de ces
manifestations
habituellement mais vous confirmer on
est dans un contexte qui n'a plus rien
d'un contexte universitaire c'est
vraiment ça qu'il faut comprendre
tolbiac n'avait plus rien d'un contexte
universitaire les lieux où se tiennent
ces d'ateliers n'ont plus rien d'un
contexte universitaire et puis en tant
que professeur de génétique
je vous confirme qu'il n'ya qu'une race
humaine en tous les cas l'intervention
des forces de police c'était le thème de
notre première question du sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité
est ce que vous êtes pour l'appel aux
forces de l'ordre pour empêcher le
blocage des universités 59% jeu 2 oui
38% donnant n'est pas surprise par ce
résultat
moi je crois que c'est la façon dont on
pose la question est compliquée à la
fois bien sûr qu' il faut empêcher
blocage dans les universités bien sûr
que les universités on vous l'avait
rappelé l'habitude d'accueillir du débat
parfois de la contestation
et c'est uniquement lorsque les
présidents d'université ne se sente cuir
en capacité d'assurer la sécurité sur
leur propre campus que les forces de
l'ordre interviennent et là c'est normal
parce que on n'est plus dans un contexte
université vous avez évoqué des tags
antisémites
est ce que vous auriez signé le
manifeste du parisien l'a publiée
dimanche sur le nouvel antisémitisme
dans notre pays alors en tant que
ministre je pense qu'il vaut mieux agir
que signer des pétitions
c'est ce qu'on a fait le 19 mars dernier
en annonçant le plan de lutte contre le
racisme et d'antisémitisme avec des
actions très précieuse acquis qui ont
d'ores et déjà commencé été mise en
place
donc voilà je pense que c'est ça le rôle
du gouvernement après si vous me
demandez si à titre individuel j'aurais
pu signer c'est depuis dix ans qu'il
sait faire cette transition
je suis 100% d'accord avec tout ce
qu'elle contient mais en tout cas elle a
le mérite de poser un vrai problème est
de poser un problème qui est une réalité
aujourd'hui on a encore pu constater ces
derniers jours et c'est un vrai sujet
peut-être encore une question sur les
examens vous les avez évoqué madame la
ministre monsieur qu'est ce que vous
donnez comme garantie aujourd'hui aux
exams aux étudiants qui vont passer
leurs examens est ce que tous vont
pouvoir les passer dans de bonnes
conditions alors bon on parle évidemment
des blocages de sites
on parle aussi de
la grève qui se poursuit à la sncf qui a
des étudiants qui galèrent tous les
jours pour se rendre sur les lieux
d'examen
est ce qu'il ya des aménagements qui
sont envisageables dans quelle mesure
alors ça évidemment le principe c'est
que les examens auront lieu et que cette
année universitaire soit validé oui ça
c'est vraiment extrêmement important a
pas de vols mais il faut bien comprendre
que c'est l'état qui certifie les
diplômes qui sont donnés dans les
universités les universités organisent
les examens l'état certifier les
diplômes il y aura pas de diplôme
certifié par l'état
si les examens n'ont pas eu lieu donc
c'est très important que ces examens
aient lieu parce qu'une fois de plus on
a les étudiants internationaux qui
doivent rejoindre leur université
d'origine avec leurs semestre validé on
a les étudiants qui travaillent pour
payer leurs études
et si leur diplôme n'est pas belle idée
qui vont devoir recommencer on a les
étudiants boursiers qui dort avec les
éventuels perturbateurs on n'a pas joué
à cache-cache je vous le dit la semaine
dernière
7000 étudiants ont passé leurs examens
une fois de plus je crois qu'il faut
sept mille étudiants de tolbiac et
beaucoup plus sur la france entière
je crois qu'une fois de plus il faut
ramener les choses à la réalité il y à
certains sites sur lesquels il ya des
difficultés mais même sur ce site là les
examens sont en train de se tenir avec
un bâtiment bloqués et les examens dans
l'amphithéâtre d'à côté alors que le
mans auront lieu vous avez eu l'occasion
de croiser aujourd'hui je crois valérie
pécresse
la présidente lr2
ce matin voilà condorcet pour
l'inauguration d'un bâtiment est là il
était à votre poste c'est ce que c'est
que la contestation des réformes
elle vous soutient elle salue une
réforme courageuse ou c'est un soutien
important pour vous aujourd'hui mais de
madame pécresse à la fois madame
pécresse comme madame sur asos on se
sont exprimés et ont dit toutes les deux
effectivement il y avait un problème
auquel personne ne s'était attaqué
frontalement jusqu'à maintenant qui est
ce taux extrêmement faible de réussite
en première année et cette sélection à
30,68 en première année en moyenne
c'est insupportable insupportable pour
les étudiants insupportable pour les
enseignants les enseignants chercheurs
ça doit être insupportable pour toute la
société
et justement c'est pour ça que donc vous
avez mis sur les rails cette réforme
dont on va parler tout de suite avec la
deuxième question de l'épreuve de vérité
que 20 vous posez lucile bréau
[Musique]
alors madame la ministre est ce que vous
êtes satisfaite aujourd'hui de la mise
en oeuvre de parcours sup je rappelle
que un peu plus de 800 mille lycéens ont
exprimé leurs voeux est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes satisfait de la
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
alors il faut il faut séparer parcours
succès une plateforme et questionnement
elle a extrêmement bien fonctionné
jusqu'à présent les lycéens ont pu ont
pu faire leurs voeux ont pu finalement
exprimé pour la première fois la réalité
de leur choix et la réalité de leurs
sauts et puisque rien était imposé ils
ont pu avoir pour la première fois des
informations qui était identique pour
l'ensemble des lycéens
et ça je crois que ça a été aussi saluée
par les familles et par les lycéens
eux-mêmes lorsqu'ils avaient dans leur
entourage
d'autres personnes qui avaient utilisé
la précédente plateforme saas est le
point de départ évidemment un
accompagnement mais c'est important
c'est important de parler de cette phase
d'orientation en fait qui a qui s'est
tenue pendant toute cette période
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars avec un
véritable accompagnement des professeurs
principaux qui ont fait un travail
absolument formidable avec les lycéens
qui nous ont dit que le fait d'avoir des
groupes plus petit ça leur avait permis
de se mettre autour d'une table et de
parler avec les lycéens de leurs projets
d'avenir choses qui n'avaient pas
forcément le temps de faire auparavant
et c'est une mission qui leur étaient
pas qui leur était pas confiée donc
heureux s'inquiètent de ne pas être
admis voulu quoique il sera forcément
mieux ou pas forcément je ressens tu
alors j'entends leur inquiétude d'autant
plus qu' évidemment là encore un certain
nombre de personnes cherchent à les
inquiéter en leur racontant des choses
qui sont absolument fausses sur sur
cette plateforme pour l'instant les leaf
et n'ont pas bougé vous croisez les
doigts
non je croisais les doigts je remercie
tous les professeurs qui les accompagne
tous les jours et qui avec eux ont pris
le temps d'expliquer qu'elle était
l'esprit de cette réforme
l'année dernière on a tiré 65 musiciens
au sort pour savoir si oui ou non ils
pourraient aller dans la filière de leur
choix
on les a obligés à 810 1000 lycéens
comment est ce que vous pouvez les
rassurer individuellement d'abord tout
simplement que son dossier puisque ces
engagements soient examinées vraiment
individuellement alors il faut bien
comprendre que cette réforme dans sa
globalité elle a été co construite avec
les acteurs de l'enseignement supérieur
que ce soient les représentants des
personnels les représentants des
étudiants
les chefs d'établissement et tout l'été
toute la durée de cette discussion nous
avons co construit la solution pour
sortir du tirage au sort ensemble et
pour commencer à résoudre la question de
70 % d'échec en première année
tout l'été je leur ai dit est ce que sur
cette mesure là vous pensez que nous
serons en mesure de la mettre en place
parce que c'est extrêmement important de
mettre les lycéens dans une situation où
ils peuvent faire confiance à
l'enseignement supérieur tout l'été la
réponse a été oui j'ai eu l'occasion
d'aller dans les universités et de voir
les gens qui sont au travail autour de
ces dossiers pour préparer les
accompagnements pour la rentrée on a
travaillé avec les recteurs et les
présidents d'université les présidents
ont indiqué partout où ils avaient
besoin de place on a financé 19000 passe
supplémentaire à redon mais exactement
la hausse était nécessaire tous ces
bacheliers qu'ils auront une place
quelque part à la rentrée est ce que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui garantir ce que
je que c'est ce qui les inquiète c'est
où est ce que je serai en septembre mais
si vous me permettez je vais vous
répondre en deux temps d'abord certains
bacheliers n'ont demandé que des
filières sélectives et s'ils n'ont
demandé que des filières sélectives la
chose que je peux leur garantir c'est
que la commission rectorales prendra
contact avec eux s'ils n'ont aucun de
leur choix en filières sélectives et
leur fera des propositions au plus près
de leur choix ça c'est la première chose
que je peux garantir la deuxième chose
c'est que pour tous les lycéens qui ont
demandé des filières non sélective nous
avons d'ores et déjà financées
dix neuf mille places supplémentaires en
regardant très exactement où on avait
besoin de ces places et au fur et à
mesure que la procédure se déroulera
nous pourrons ouvrir encore d'autres
places la seule limite si je puis dire
c'est les murs de l'université dans
toutes les salles sont prises quand tous
les amphis sont son prix évidemment là
dans cette université là ce n'est pas
possible mais on ne s'arrête pas pour
autant
et là encore le rôle de la commission
électorale c'est de signaler tout ce qui
est possible dans les universités
alentours ou dans d'autres finissent mal
an prochain il ya des lycéens qui
peuvent se retrouver sans affectation en
alliant de l'année dernière l'année
dernière il a tiré au sort 65 mille
étudiants et il est resté au mois de
septembre 89 bacheliers généraux parce
qu'on n'avait pas réussi à les joindre
donc si on a réussi à faire ça l'année
dernière avec aucune anticipation
vous comprenez bien que notre ambition
notre volonté c'est que cette année on
sera en capacité d'accueillir chaque
bachelier qui le souhaitent dans
l'enseignement supérieur alors on nous
vous écoutons attentivement madame la
ministre vous parler de l'orientation de
l'accompagnement des lycéens n'est ce
pas mais les français ils ont compris
qu'il s'agissait d'une sélection écoute
et voilà le résultat de la deuxième
question de notre sondage opinionway
parcours sup introduite et la sélection
à l'entrée en fac et bien les gens
répondent oui à 66% voilà c'est ce
qu'ils ont compris alors pourquoi ne pas
assumer madame vidal cette notion de
sélection à l'entrée en fac pour éviter
ce que vous avez rappelé effectivement
la sélection à l'issue de la première
année par l'échec
c'était une question de manque pas du
tout ce n'est pas une question de mots
ce n'est pas de la sélection et quand je
vous parle d'accompagnement en fait ce
que je veux vous dire c'est que
lorsqu'on a le baccalauréat et que l'on
souhaite s'engager donc ses études
supérieures il y a toujours des moyens
de réussir ce sera parfois plus long on
devra parfois prendre le temps de
s'orienter mieux on devrait être
accompagné par des professeurs mais il
n'y a pas de fatalité a échoué dans
l'enseignement supérieur je peux vous
donner un exemple moi je je j'ai
enseigné je voulais dire toute ma vie
est en tout cas toute l'année j'ai tenu
à le faire aussi en premier cycle et en
première année je me rappelle d'une
étudiante qui est arrivé avec un
baccalauréat qu'il avait préparé à des
techniques d'analysés médicales elle est
venue me voir à la fin du cours elle m'a
dit madame je comprends pas les mots que
vous employez je comprends pas pourtant
joseph sur j'aime la biologie j'ai fait
ça jusqu'à mon bac je veux y arriver
qu'est ce que je lui dis je lui ai dit
en fait tu es doué et tu sais faire des
choses que les autres ne savent pas
faire tu sais utiliser des pipettes tu
sais faire des examens
donc on va rentrer avec toi par les
travaux pratiques et quand on va rentrer
avec toi par les travaux pratiques
tu vas te rendre compte que finalement
tu peux aller
arrières latéraux rouge et appuyez sur
votre expérience personnelle peut être
vous même vous avez également pousser
donc je ne suis pas un cas unique j'ai
fait ça dans une équipe pédagogique
je connais dans toutes les universités
les gens et pour la seule différence
c'est que maintenant la loi permet que
ces initiatives soit reconnu qu'elle ne
soit pas faite sous forme de bénévolat
ou sous forme de petites
expérimentations mais on va pouvoir les
généraliser accord parce qu'il n'ya pas
une inquiétude légitime sur les
algorithmes qui ont une part de
l'importante dans dans l'orientation des
lycéens est ce que vous allez faire
toute la lumière ce qu'on connaîtra
c'est la grande question du moment
1 comment ces algorithmes eux
fonctionnent des soeurs il ne soit pas
piégeux
ce concept engagé et c'est prévu par la
loi la totalité des algorithmes seront
publiés donc ça c'est je pense même
inscrit un script ne s'est pas dans la
loi c'est dans le décret d'application
de la loi donc les algorithmes seront
absolument connu et la suge j'allais
dire il n'y a pas de sujet paul autant
il ya une contestation des
universitaires de certains d'entre eux à
tout le moins qui refusent de trier
c'est le receleur mots les élèves qui ne
veulent pas jouer le jeu
alors qu'est ce que c'est un acte de
désobéissance un acte d'autorité
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez à ces
enseignants du supérieur qui refusent de
d'étudier les dossiers de parcours su
mais je pense que une fois encore ils
n'ont pas complètement compris quelle
était la philosophie
donc ça veut dire que j'ai pas réussi a
alors expliqué qu'elle était l'objectif
l'objectif c'est en aucun cas de dire
non mais l'objectif c'est d'accueillir
la diversité quand vous êtes ambitieux
on à 96 mille enseignants et
enseignants-chercheurs dans
l'enseignement supérieur
on a 400 qui disent qu'il ne souhaite
pas le faire les autres sont en train de
le faire moi je pense que ces
enseignants chercheurs ils viendront et
ils viendront aussi parce que leurs
étudiants leur demanderons à un moment
et leur diront mais moi aussi je veux
avoir des travaux dirigés en plus moi
aussi je veux qu'on tienne compte du
fait que j'ai besoin d'être plus aider
pourquoi vous ne le faites pas dans
cette filière et et ils leur coupent
d'accord là vous dites que les lycéens
pourrait au pire en une certaine manière
obtenir comme réponse est oui si alors
que c'est bien cela pourquoi ce serait
pire
ce serait alors une opposition canton
comme opportunité on peut leur dire oui
c'est si il y a
complément de formation mais là il ya un
hic c'est ce que disent tous les
présidents d'université avec qui vous
êtes en contact évidemment
quotidiennement le brême des moyens
écouter jean françois abalo des quais le
président de l'université de nanterre il
vous interpelle madame la ministre
accompagner les publics les plus
fragiles
c'est une noble ambition comment comptez
vous aider les universités à déployer
ces dispositifs
sachant que les universités souffrent
d'un sous investissement sachant que là
le coût moyen d'un étudiant est deux
fois inférieur à celui d'un élève de
classe préparatoire
n'y at-il pas à ce point où nous nous
trouvons à penser un plan ambitieux pour
accompagner les universités et leur
permettre dédié à la réussite du plus
grand nombre d'étudiants
ce plan ambitieux vous allez les
réclamer mais bien sûr mais ce plan
ambitieux je tombe bien il faut le
replacer dans ce qui a déjà été fait le
budget 2010 8 des universités ses 234
millions d'euros de plus par rapport à
l'année dernière
donc vous dites c'est suffisant laissez
moi juste terminée je ne dis pas que
c'est suffisant je rappelle juste que le
gouvernement a déjà fait à cette
augmentation budgétaire de l'année 2018
le gouvernement a souhaité ajouter un
milliard d'euros spécifiquement fléchés
sur l'orientation et l'accueil en
première année d'accord donc c'est un
milliard d'euros qui sont concentrés sur
cet accueil en première année mais ceci
dit et jean françois baldé le sait très
bien les discussions ne sont pas
terminées parce que moi je veux qu'on
aille jusqu'au bout de cette réforme
je veux qu'on reconnaisse l'engagement
des enseignants des enseignants
chercheurs des équipes pédagogiques
y compris des administratifs qui
accueillent ces étudiants je veux qu'on
fasse en sorte que la carrière des
enseignants-chercheurs ne soit pas
fondée uniquement sur leurs publications
scientifiques
je veux que l'accueil à l'université
soit une véritable variable prise en
compte dans ces carrières
donc nous sommes en train de discuter
sur dalle indemnitaire nous allons
discuter sur les plans de carrière nous
recevons toutes les organisations
représentatives des étudiants et des
personnels dans le courant de l'année
ben nous recevrons avec le premier
ministre la conférence des présidents
d'université pour continuer à travailler
sur ses moyens c'est pas c'est pas de la
faute de ce gouvernement si ça fait 20
ans que le budget des universités est en
permanence sous-estimé donc si je prends
bien vous avez la conviction
j'ai sous-estimé j'ai été présidente
d'université je sais ce que ça
signifiait d'annoncer la création de
milliers de postes mais dans le même
temps de ne pas compenser les
augmentations de salaires ça se traduit
par quoi ça se traduit par le fait qu'
on embauche personne parce que l'argent
qui arrive pour embaucher sert à payer
les salaires des gens qui sont là pour
la première fois cette année on a ouvert
des postes pour l'accueil en premier
cycle et on a mis en face les deux dj
qui correspondent le fil dernière
question pour cette partie un mot sur la
réussite en licence c'est un peu votre
combat la loi en tout cas fixe tel un
objectif à atteindre
on sait qu'aujourd'hui le seuil est très
très bas est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous fixé
un objectif atteint l'objectif à
atteindre ne sera en aucun cas un
objectif chiffré par an le l'ambition
otages à partir de quel miracle pour
sourds du beh au lieu d'une génération
pas là encore là encore je crois qu'il
faut vraiment comprendre ce que veut
faire cette loi alors compris qu'est ce
que vous voulez vous allez comprendre
pourquoi l'absence de données ce type de
statistiques par année
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que les
bacheliers qui entre à l'université on
leur donne pas seulement une carte
d'étudiant on les accompagne pour qu'ils
réussissent leur diplôme que ce soit en
trois ans que ce soit en quatre ans que
ce soit en se réorientant mais en
gardant les acquis de l'année qu'ils ont
déjà fait ce qui nous importe c'est de
mettre les jeunes dans une situation de
réussite et de confiance en eux et
d'arrêter de les mettre dans une
situation d'échec qui y compris
psychologiquement influent sur la façon
dont ensuite il se projette dans
l'avenir et dans la société de
valorisation de l'accueil un accueil
bienveillant de toute cette diversité un
accueil très inclusif et c'est pour ça
qu effectivement il faut des moyens et
c'est pour ça que tout ne sera pas
parfait dès la première
et c'est pour ça qu'il faudra qu'il va
carthage d'expérience ou de vendée dont
ça ne ça ne peut pas se traduire par un
chiffre c'est parce qu'on a des
traînards on parle étudiants on part de
tellement bas on espère que ça le plus
vite possible
est ce que votre calme que vous affichez
encore ce soir est un atout dans
l'épreuve de force que vous traversez
écoutez je sais c'est mon tempérament je
vois là je sais pas si je suis pas
particulièrement calme particulièrement
énervé par contre c'est à dire moi je ne
pourrais jamais m'empêcher je pense
d'être professeur donc
j'explique une fois deux fois trois fois
c'est ça la pédagogie c'est la
répétition et bien vous allez pouvoir
encore vous expliquer avec la troisième
question maintenant de l'épreuve de
vérité que va vous poser paul aubry ya
[Musique]
évidemment les classements
internationaux sont rarement flatteur
alors est ce que l'université française
peut encore tenir son rang face à la
concurrence mondiale alors sur la
question des classements c'est un sujet
qui est extrêmement intéressant et
curieusement on a trois principaux à le
pousser dans shanghai
oui mais il faut comprendre d'où
viennent les choses alors là encore
ajuste en quelques mots le classement de
shanghai il a été créé parce que le
gouvernement chinois voulait investir
massivement dans quelques-unes de ces
universités et a demandé à une de ces
universités d'imaginer un classement qui
lui permettrait de voir à partir de
quand son investissement serait visible
sur des critères internationaux comme
l'obtention des prix nobel
l'attraction de prix nobel et un certain
nombre de critères qui ont été
considérées par la colonne on va dire
l'ensemble des pays comme les critères
les seuls critères d'évaluation
d'université se sont loin d'être les
seuls donc c'est important d'être
présent dans shanghai mais je pense
qu'il faut donner à shanghai la place
qui l'intéressent asseman vous juger la
créativité l'attractivité des
universités françaises
elle se juge à la capacité qu'ont les
universités d'attirer des étudiants
internationaux et d'attirer des
chercheurs de haut niveau là et ça pour
le moment
nous devons plutôt bien puisque nous
avons attirer plus d'étudiants
internationaux que les précédentes
années et que nous sommes tout à fait en
capacité d'attirer des jeunes talents
puisque dans les procédures de
recrutement national sur les concours de
la fonction publique
que ce soit les enseignants chercheurs
ou les chercheurs on a à peu près 30% de
recrutement internationaux donc la
france reste un pays attractif par son
instrument supérieur et la recherche
le prix nobel d'économie jean tirole et
critiqué récemment le fonctionnement des
universités et vous serez d'accord avec
lui quand il réclame plus d'ambition
pour nos universités en france il
déclarait ceci jean tirole il ya
quelques jours dans les échos il a
évidemment pour pour la sélection il dit
que l'université a déboulé au pied face
aux grandes écoles hautement sélective
mieux de thé et agile
grâce à une gouvernance plus souple est
ce qu'il dit vrai le prix nobel
d'économie
alors là encore c'est intéressant quand
on lit tout son arc toustou la totalité
de son interview il ya des points avec
lesquels je suis d'accord d'autres avec
lesquels je ne suis pas d'accord
il y en a un que nous partageons
absolument c'est l'ambition nécessaire
pour l'université française
d'accord je vais vous donner un autre
point de vue cette fois dans le figaro
c'était il ya quelques jours vendredi je
crois les céistes libéral gaspard koenig
qui rallie choisi ses activités voilà il
ya eu des prises de position il dit il a
dit avoir fui d'université mais il dit
ceci à propos de les litres entre
guillemets l'élite il parle d'aidé par
an peut être informés ou des couches
sociales supérieures l'élite fait tout
pour éviter ce purgatoire il parle de
l'université à ses rejetons s'était dit
envoie ses élèves ses enfants en prépa à
l'étranger dans des établissements
privés alors qu'est ce que vous dites là
vous serez pas d'accord du tout sur
toute la ligne
non non je ne sont pas une part de
vérité malgré tout bien qu'on puisse que
déplorer alors pour moi
l'université reste un lieu qui est tout
à fait particulier dans l'enseignement
supérieur
c'est le lieu où à la fois se construit
la connaissance puisqu'il y aller
laboratoires de recherche qui sont en
général des laboratoires mixtes mais qui
peuvent être des laboratoires purement
universitaire et c'est les gens qui
construit
la connaissance qui la transmettent
c'est à dire que au delà de la
connaissance transmises
on transmet la façon dont on crée de la
connaissance
et ça c'est unique donc évidemment que
les universités françaises de ce point
de vue là comme l'ensemble des
universités garde cette spécificité
cette particularité
après je dirais pas que tout est rose
dans les universités françaises mais je
dis que voilà ce sont les lieux où les
choses fonctionnent comme ça où il est
aussi important d'apprendre à apprendre
que d'apprendre les choses en tant que
tel et où surtout on explique comment on
se sent comment on questionne les choses
acquises pour obtenir de la connaissance
nouvelle pour répondre à gaspard koenig
est ce que vous appelez ces gens-là
cette élite dans laquelle je crois il
s'inclut à faire un espèce d'actes
patriotique et de dire inscrivez vos
enfants à l'université après tout fait
confiance aussi au système éducatif à la
française mais je pense que les gens
font aller on va inscrire vos enfants
dans des prépas à l'étranger à l'as tu
es là encore je crois que il faut faire
il faut faire attention à ne pas
généraliser la pratique de quelques-uns
s'il ya des gens qui souhaitent que
leurs enfants aillent faire leurs études
ou le début des études à l'étranger par
écoute et voilà qu'il le fasse c'est pas
un sujet le sujet c'est que l'état
français
garantie à tous les enfants de la nation
une éducation de l'enseignement
supérieur de qualité et c'est ça
vraiment pour moi le fond du sujet et
c'est pas seulement une carte d'étudiant
c'est aussi la capacité à réussir
alors il ya aussi la capacité à se payer
des études vous l'avez rappelé
effectivement beaucoup d'étudiants n'ont
pas pris le mouvement en marche ces
dernières semaines parce qu'ils
expliquent bas on peut pas rater notre
année on a un job parfois deux jobs on
n'a pas de boer qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez annoncer promettent je ne sais
pas est ce que c'est un nouveau combat
aussi pour lutter contre une forme de
paupérisation des étudiants dans notre
pays ça se traduit notamment par le fait
qu' il se soigne
mal d'abord effectivement pour moi la
réussite ça inclut aussi la qualité de
la vie des étudiants donc c'est pour ça
qu'avec le premier ministre la première
chose qu'on nous avons souhaité faire
c'est faire en sorte que dès cette année
la rentrée 2008 coûtera 100 millions
d'euros deux mois aux étudiants et à
leurs familles que la rentrée 2010 est
parce que nous avons supprimé les
cotisations spécifiques aux régimes de
sécurité sociale et sûrs nous allons
mettre en place dans les établissements
des centres de santé nous travaillons à
ce que justement le la psychologie de
l'étudiant son stress son mal-être
puissent être mieux pris en compte et
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est tout l'intérêt de dire à
un étudiant tu as réussi trois unités
d'enseignement même si l'année on compte
dix cas l'importance tu en as réussi
trois parce que c'était ça ton défi
plutôt que de lui dire battant a raté
sept et donc tu as raté vous voyez tout
ça c'est aussi une façon de remettre
l'étudiant au coeur du système les
étudiants qui travaillent pour payer
leurs études
bien sûr que je les comprends tout à
fait je vois même tout à fait ce qu'ils
sont en train de vivre
c'est très important évidemment pour eux
que leurs diplômes garde de la valeur
nous travaillons aussi à faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus d'emplois étudiants
dans les universités parce que moi je
suis convaincu que il y a beaucoup plus
d'intérêt pour un étudiant à permettre
une ouverture dans une bibliothèque
universitaire le week end que d'être
obligé d'aller travailler dans le
secteur
j'ai une question je vais utiliser le
mot sélection madame la ministre
à quoi devez-vous votre sélection par
emmanuel macron pour entrer dans le
gouvernement
je sais pas si j'ai été sélectionnée
d'une forme ou d'une autre
voilà c'est vous voyez tout de suite les
choses sont différentes et on préfère
toujours être choisir qu être
sélectionné on avait eu l'occasion de
d'un déjeuner ensemble lorsqu'il était
ministre et que j'étais présidente
d'université
il avait souhaité rencontrer des
présidents d'université qui avait décidé
de prendre en main leur établissement de
les faire à la fois
l'emblème de mon université c'est est
ancré dans son des territoires ouverte à
l'international
c'est vraiment ce qu'on avait ce qu'on
avait envie dans le semble absolument
dit sophia antipolis et donc il voulait
rencontrer des présidents d'université
s'est donc fait mouche qui notamment
avait été sélectionneur les programmes
d'initiative d'excellence là où on les
attendait pas forcément simplement parce
que il y avait peut-être une forme
d'originalité dans notre projet qui a
été reconnue par le jury au nom après la
présidence macron ce soir nous sommes un
premier tour donc pas très bien très
beau souvenir pour moi en tout cas un
très beau souvenir et un an après ce qui
a été fait par le président ça vous
semble satisfaisant le maquereau nisme
c'est quelque chose qui vous convainc
toujours le je crois que le formidable
espoir qui a été qui a été porté tout au
long de la campagne
et puis cette façon de dire que l'avenir
ce sera aussi ce que nous en ferons tous
ensemble et que c'est très important de
de garder cet optimisme de d'essayer
toujours de voir le verre à moitié plein
plutôt que le verre à moitié vide de se
rendre compte que évidemment l'état est
là pour nous protéger mais on peut aussi
se demander tous les jours qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire pour que notre pays
aille mieux
tout ça moi je le ressens toujours
intacte dans la volonté du président de
faire avancer la france et l'europe et
au sans doublure de bons aussi et au
sein du gouvernement aussi bien sûr je
crois qu'on est on est tous dans cette
dans cette dynamique
voilà je sais c'est un engagement que
personnel extrêmement fort ce n'est pas
notre profession d'être ministre ce
n'était pas notre vocation de devenir
ministre
nous avons tous choisi de donner une
part de notre vie à notre pays
en exerçant cette mission je crois qu'on
est nombreux à partager ce sentiment
un mot peut-être de la rencontre entre
emmanuel macron et donald trump au aux
etats-unis le président va atterrir
d'ici une petite heure au aux états unis
on se souvient de l'appel qu'il avait
lancé quand donald trump a quitté
l'accord de paris il a dit aux
chercheurs installés aux etats-unis qui
travaillent sur les questions
climatiques
venez la france peut être une terre
refuge on est prêt à vous accueillir
est ce que vous savez aujourd'hui
combien ont répondu à cet appel combien
ou ont toqué à la porte
bon bien sûr le premier appel il ya eu à
peu près 450 dossiers déposés pas
uniquement des états unis mais une
grosse moitié venant des états unis
une première vague de 18 sélectionnés
une deuxième vague en ce moment de 14
sélectionnés et l'allemagne nous
accompagne aussi donc c'est un mouvement
qui s'enclenche et la gauche radicale en
allemagne mâcon qu'il va faire ami ami
avec dans notre homme qui célèbre l
amérique est aujourd'hui on a des
réfugiés intellectuelle des chercheurs
pour entraver leur pays et qui viennent
trouver refuge en france par définition
la recherche c'est quelque chose
d'international alors quand on est
empêché dans son pays c'est important de
savoir qu'on peut continuer dans
d'autres pays merci beaucoup madame la
ministre de variables avec nous dans
cette période toujours aussi agité mais
bon on a suivi avec vous à les derniers
événements et notamment on a pu faire au
cours de cette émission le point sur ce
mouvement étudiant qui ne l'est pas tout
à fait si l'on vous écoute en tous les
cas dans ces manifestations de blocages
merci à vous deux merci à tous a très
vite merci mme hanska
[Musique]